bonjour à tous le département de La
Réunion est au plus près des réunionnés
toute génération confondu et dans bien
des domaines parmi ces compétences le
volet social et notamment
l'accompagnement dans l'insertion à
l'emploi allons retrouver maxonard
directeur du TAS Sud-Ouest au
département de La
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Réunion bonjour monsieur maxonard
bonjour expliquez-nous vre fonction
alors ma fonction c'est de faire en
sorte que tous les services du
département qui se retrouvent au sein
d'une maison départementale apportte des
réponses aux difficultés de de la
population nous sommes sur le forum de
l'action sociale sud-ouest quel est
l'objectif de cet événement de faire en
sorte qu'on est sur un même site tous
les partenaires qui vent dans le champ
de l'action sociale et de l'insertion
pour apporter des réponses concrètes à
tous les publics qui viennent nous voir
pour faciliter leur insertion
professionnelle alors nous avons ici des
accompagnants et des Bénéfic officiè et
je crois même que vous avez prévu un
rendez-vous avec une bénéficiaire tout à
fait vous allez à la rencontre
d'Isabelle elle vous attend il vous
expliquera l'accompagnement je la
retrouver tout de
suite bonjour Isabelle bonjour
racontez-nous votre histoire donc étant
donné que ben je suis maman de d'un
enfant porteur d'handicap ça a été un
petit peu compliqué d'allier ma vie de
famille et ma vie professionnelle et
comment avez-vous été accompagné j'ai
été accompagné par département qui m'a
orienté et qui m'a conseillé dans cette
démarche d'ouverture d'entreprise alors
parlez-nous de votre entreprise
actuellement je fais de la création de
d'accessoires de mode des trousses des
pochettes avec du tifu et tout ça alors
c'est une bien belle insertion quels
sont vos projets d'avenir maintenant ben
mes projets d'avenir c'est de continuer
en créant des choses avec du cuir des
matières un petit peu plus lourde et
notamment j'ai été financé par le
département pour une nouvelle machine
voilà qui va me permettre de réaliser
tout ça très bien merci Isabelle et
bonne continuation merci à vous nous
l'avons vu ce salon est très important
pour les bénéficiaires mais ce forum est
également très utile pour les
professionnels nous allons le voir avec
Claudine qui accompagne depuis 20 ans
des Réunionnais et des
Réunionnaises bonjour Claudine bonjour
Alors vous accompagnez les bénéficiaires
du RSA depuis plus de 20 ans parlez-nous
de votre travail notre rôle en tant que
consillère d'ination c'est d'accompagner
c'est-à-dire d'aider les bénéficiaires
du RSA à définir et conc er un projet
professionnel parlez-nous des
dispositifs mis en place par le
Département je vais pas pouvoir tous les
énumérer mais nous avons Lafi donc
l'aide financière à l'insertion c'est
une aide donc qui va permettre aux
personnes qui reprennent une activité ou
une formation de les aider dans leurs
dépenses par exemple achat de matériel
pour une formation et cetera vous aviez
également le a plus dont vous nous
parlez c'est un dispositif qui vient
compenser la perte du RSA vous savez
lorsqu'on prend une activité et ben le
RSA va baisser le R+ viendra compenser
cette perte donc c'est une mesure
vraiment incitative c'est un montant de
90 à 600 € versé mensuellement et ici au
Forum de l'insertion tous les
professionnels travaillent main dans la
main c'est une volonté du département
c'est une volonté et ben nous avons la
possibilité de pouvoir échanger et et et
aussi benah connaître ce que bah nos
partenaires proposent c'est un un
partage mutuel je dirais très bien merci
Claudine je vous en
prie Monsieur hard vous aviez raison il
y a vraiment une volonté sur ce forum de
travailler ensemble c'est vraiment
l'état d'esprit de ce forum agir main
dans la main avec tous les partenaires
pour assurer un meilleur accompagnement
de nos bénéficiaires du RSA d'ailleurs
je vous propose d'aller à la rencontre
de Madame sigismo vice-présidente en
charge de l'insertion dans la
collectivité et bien merci Monsieur
ogard pour ces informations
merci bonjour madame sigismo bonjour
alors ici nous l'avons vu l'accent est
mis sur le rapport à l'humain l'humain
est au cœur de nos préoccupations parce
que chaque personne à ces problèmes avec
l'ensemble des partelaires nous allons
répondre à chaque point des difficultés
que rencontrent nos bénéficiaires et les
accompagner à un projet de vie durable
ce forum de l'insertion qui est déjà un
succès est-il amené à se reproduire il
va se reproduire dans tout le territoire
parce que c'est un travail de cohérence
de coordination pour l'ensemble des
réunionnés merci Madame cismo merci à
bientôt le département des gén c'est
déjà fini on se retrouve très vite pour
un nouvel épisode à
[Musique]
bientôt